rien d'extraordinaire n'arrive aux
jeunes comme des bons petits peut-être
max et comme neo dans matrix
sauf qu'à l'est dans l'arkansas et bien
d'autres mais c'est madame je suis
célèbre sur le net
bonjour chers élèves de benton ville je
suis atticus vertu mon objectif a
toujours été de construire un avenir
meilleur
je suis heureux de vous annoncer que
cinq étudiants ont été sélectionnés ils
auront la chance de venir dans un manoir
c'est pas vrai ces cinq étudiants
participeront rage le gagnant de ce jeu
recevra la clé dont la noire je suis
certain que monsieur ouverte et ne
choisit que les meilleurs la crème de la
crème qui m'appelle max le diminutif de
matinée
ce jeu pourrait changer à jamais novik
par écoeurer domineront falloir ce soir
il y aura des jeux en réalité virtuelle
[Musique]
j'ai entendu dire je faisais des
expériences sur des humains
le manoir aurait un cerveau bienvenue au
manoir est tu sais moi ou on dirait que
ce foutu manoir parle si on décide d'y
entrer il se glissera à l'intérieur de
votre tête et explosera von roll
bienvenue dans la partie gros menteur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
serait plus toujours comme ça comme quoi
méchant
allez vous en dis si tout de suite vous
pouvez le sortir de là
ça n'avait rien d'un jeu et panneaux
pourquoi tu nous regardes comme ça
even